To get started, we want to give you
a big picture view of machine learning.
What it is?
Where it came from?
And what you'll learn in
this nano degree program?
Machine learning borrows
heavily from two fields,
artificial intelligence and
data science.
So, we'll start by talking
a bit about those areas and
how machine learning fits in.
Using some material from one of Georgia
Tech's artificial intelligence classes
and one of you to ask these
data science classes.
Then we'll move on to machine
learning more closely and
start looking at Georgia Tech's
machine learning class and
ask these machine learning class.
Finally, we'll conclude by looking at
some of the basics of machine learning,
like classification and regression,
in order to get a feel for
how machine learning is really
about building models of data.